How do we know that punishment is punishment? It's because the Shrine Maiden
has been trusted.
Isn't that just what the Sosei Sect is saying?
People have created imaginary gods to
punish them.  It's strange to let someone die for a foreign country.This
is a barbaric country that protects beastmen.We don't know what they're doing behind the scenes.After
all,
Henry has met people from other countries and beastmen.  It's
so scary that I can't even get close to you.
This is what it feels like. This is the true meaning of this feeling of incongruity. I feel like I'm a chosen one who is manipulated by words and discriminates
against and looks down on others. I can't even call myself a blessed woman. I never thought that
someone like you could
be such a despicable person.  I
didn't.
[Music] I'm
sorry.
[Music]